>>> IT ALL HAPPENED SO FAST.
>> OH, KENAN THOMPSON, THE
LEGEND, MAN.
>> KEKE, YOU HAVING FUN?
>> YES.
I'M WORKING WITH MY IDOL.
>> STOP IT.
>> NO, NO, I GREW UP WATCHING
YOU AS A KID.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO WORK WITH
YOU.
I ACTUALLY HAVE AN IDEA FOR A
PROJECT I WOULD LOVE TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT LATER.
>> ANYTHING WITH KEKE PALMER,
I'M THERE, NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
>> REALLY?
BECAUSE I GOT THIS IDEA FOR A
REBOOT
♪ SIT DOWN ON THE COUCH AND LOOK
ON THAT TELLY ♪
♪ KENAN AND KELLY GON BREAK ALL
THE RULES ♪
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE
A STREAMING THEORY.
I WOULD HAVE SAID YES TO KENAN
AND KEL, BUT NOW IT'S JUST
KELLY.
>> I TOLD THE PRODUCERS WE WROTE
IT TOGETHER.
>> RIGBY NOW HAS FAT SUSHI.
>> MAYBE TOO FRESH.
>> KELLY, I THINK THAT SALMON
YOU CAUGHT MIGHT BE A PIRANNA.
>> KEL'S FAVORITE CATCH PHRASE
WAS UH-OH, HERE IT GOES.
BUT HERE'S WAS OH, HERE'S THE
BUTTON.
>> YOU CAN'T KEEP TAKING ORANGE
SODAS.
>> JUST PUT IT ON MY TAB.
I'M GOOD FOR IT.
>> OKAY.
$5,000 WORTH OF ORANGE SODAS,
KELLY.
>> DON'T YELL AT ME BECAUSE
GUESS WHAT?
I'M PREGNANT WITH YOUR CHILD.
>> KEKE WAS GUNNING FOR AN EMMY
AWARD.
SO SHE WANTED TO BRING DRAMATIC
MOMENTS IN.
I THOUGHT, THAT WON'T WORK, AND
I WAS RIGHT.
>> KELLY, DID YOU FIX THE SLUSH
MACHINE?
>> YEP.
TRY IT OUT, KENAN.
>> DON'T MIND IF I DO.
I HAVE BEEN CRAVING ONE FOR
WEEKS NOW.
THAT'S ODD.
KELLY!
WHY WOULD YOU TELL ME IT IS
FIXED?
YOU ARE SUCH AN --
>> WHAT?
AN IDIOT?
GO AHEAD.
SAY IT.
IT AIN'T LIKE I HAVEN'T HEARD IT
BEFORE.
MY MAMA USED TO GET DRUNK EVERY
DAY AND CALL ME AN IDIOT.
MY UNCLE TOLD HER TO BLAME ME
FOR MY DADDY LEAVING.
ME.
HOW YOU GOING TO BLAME A LITTLE
GIRL FOR THAT MAN BEING A
COWARD?
UH-OH, HERE COMES THE BUTTONS.
>> IT JUST STARTED, AND I THINK
WE HAVE A TONE ISSUE.
BUT PEOPLE SEEM EXCITED ABOUT
IT, I GUESS.
>> HEY, KENAN.
>> HEY, DEVON, GOOD JOB ON THE
SONG, MAN.
>> THANK YOU.
I CAN DO OTHER STUFF TOO,
THOUGH.
CHECK THIS OUT.
WELCOME TO GOOD BURGER.
>> THANK YOU.
I THINK WE ALREADY FOUND
SOMEONE.
>> HEY, EVERYBODY!
OH, I MISSED YOU.
>> OH, MAN, I MISSED YOU TOO!
>> WHO LOVES ORANGE SODA?
KEL LOVES ORANGE SODA.
OH, SWEET BABY.
>> KEL, IT'S BEEN SO LONG, MAN.
WHAT YOU BEEN UP TO?
>> HANDS UP, EVERYBODY, THIS IS
A ROBBERY.
GIVE ME ALL THE MONEY IN THE
REGISTER.
>> YOU NOT STEALING A DIME,
MR. ROBBER.
YOU BEEN WONDERING WHERE I BEEN.
I BEEN LEARNING THE ARTS OF
KARATE.
>> KEL!
OH, DON'T DIE ON ME, KEL.
NO.
>> DON'T GO INTO THE LIGHT.
>> MY BABY NEEDS HIS FATHER.
YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT, KENAN.
KEL'S THE FATHER.
I SLEPT WITH HIM JUST TO HURT
YOU.
WHY DO I HURT THE ONES I LOVE
THE MOST?
HERE IT COMES.
>> NO!
>> THE SHOW IS NOT GOOD.
BUT JORDAN PEEL CALLED AND WANTS
US TO DO A SEQUEL CALLED YEP.